[Music]
a first grader helping pets inspiring
neighbors
and making the most of distance learning
it's in our first ever edition of
what's cool at school home edition i
collected
um things for
animal shelters tara academy first
grader camden wolf was assigned a
community helper project as a part of
distance learning
he chose to help the pet rescue a path
for paws
what do you think that's going to do for
all those animals who get to get all
that great stuff
it's going to help camden stood out
front with a homemade sign
gathering supplies and food for animals
in need
kind-hearted neighbors arrived with big
hearts and full arms
blankets towels and cleaning supplies
and dog food
not to mention 22 toys 30 dog leashes
and collars
100 towels and 250 bucks
camden's neighbors octavia and rosalind
followed his lead
they chose to help three square if other
people don't get food
they don't they won't survive long these
kids were provided a
valuable lesson by those that pitched in
i
think that they felt bad for like dogs
and people
so they wanted to help since this is
what's cool at school
home edition i wanted to check in on how
navigating this surreal experience of
distance learning is going
what's good about it is you like stay at
home
but what's bad at it because when you're
at home but you still had to do some
work
you still got to do some work and i
don't like that these days
we can all relate that's as cool as
school
great job kids and we want to hear more
about the positive things that are
happening during distance learning look
we know it's tough parents it's very
challenging
but look for those good moments and send
them along to us cool at school at
eightnewsnow.com
we'll share those stories right here
every week on friday